[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
April 13th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
after introducing yourself to someone
it's pretty common to ask so what do you
do but what if asking someone about
their job wasn't the second question
you'd ask or the third or the fourth
would you know what to say next wsj work
and life columnist Rachel feinstick
explored that question and she joins me
now hey Rachel thanks for being here
thanks so much for having me I'll
refrain from asking you the question Jr
I won't tell you what I do but it has to
do with sort of like hosting things with
a microphone I'm getting some Context
Clues here
so you know being asked what do you do
seems like a pretty benign question but
when did it become taboo to ask someone
right off the bat I don't think it is
taboo I think it's still a part of us
one person I talked to said it's like
asking about the weather but I think
there has been this sense especially
over the last couple of years that
people don't want to just be defined by
what they do that they want to have a
bigger life and I think going right into
it can kind of be jarring for some folks
in this moment but in this era of
overworking and strong struggling to
find a work-life balance don't many
people feel their job is part of what
defines them yeah I talk to people who
found that their all their social media
feeds had been inundated with work that
they were kind of itching to have people
ask them that question just so they
could kind of put it out there I think
it can become this kind of low-level
status competition as another person
described it to me so yes I think this
is something that we're always kind of
battling with even as we maybe try to
change our relationship to work oh so
something like oh you're a manager well
I'm a director yeah a source for this
said to me like he feels like people are
always kind of low level sizing each
other up maybe trying to figure out who
makes more money than the other person
so there's a whole undercurrent going on
yeah yeah and when we swap our job
titles we're really like trying to say
something about how busy we are how
important we are how valuable we are you
know Rachel a few recessions ago I was
out of work for a stretch of time and I
remember cringing when somebody would
ask what I did for work because I was
out of work work but when I got a job I
couldn't wait for someone to ask so it's
still okay to ask right yeah it's
definitely still okay to ask I think the
idea behind the column was just what do
we gain if maybe we don't ask right away
what are other ways that we can kind of
connect with them relate to people and
if you happen to be someone who doesn't
want to lead with your professional self
how can you field that question because
inevitably people are going to keep
asking it I guess if you're a covert CIA
operative maybe you want to sort of like
bury that down the conversation yeah and
yet those are the people we want to talk
to about their jobs right that sounds
way more fun than like the accountant
that's true but I guess you know you
can't stop people from asking the
question but is there a creative way to
answer it or maybe work around the
question yeah definitely when you talk
to one guy who said he kind of makes a
joke out of it people ask him what he
does and he'll say that he makes the
little mini umbrellas that go in drinks
and they'll be like really and they'll
be like no not really but it just kind
of honestly like a joke can just kind of
lighten the moment I think can kind of
disruptive those rote patterns of
conversations those scripts that we all
devolve into you can also just kind of
lead with your hobbies your family other
parts of your life and then add as a
kind of last final beat an afterthought
almost in my day job I or the way I make
a living is and you're kind of throwing
it in there at the end and taking some
of the focus off of that and then one
last tip is to talk about what industry
you're in what you actually do but not
focus as much on your title or the
company you work for and the idea there
is that that might not be forever and so
that was a tip that I got from someone
who had been laid off Jr but actually
been fired and found that his identity
was pretty Tangled Up in the circle of
work friends that he had The Prestige of
his title being in management the this
brand name that he was working for in
and those are the things that can kind
of go away but maybe what you're
actually doing your profession the field
that you're in um that might be
something that people might want to
focus on is there some sort of a stigma
associated with asking someone about
their job I don't think so I think it's
still a really Common Place question I
think there is just a growing sense from
a lot of people and I've heard from tons
of people since this story was written
by people who don't want to be judged by
their job anymore but no I still think
it's a socially acceptable thing to ask
I think the one awkward moment that
people might fall into is if someone has
been laid off especially in this economy
and that can obviously be might be a
hurtful thing to have kind of pushed up
to the surface I guess I'm in between
jobs as a standard answer yeah I'm in
between jobs or even someone told me to
focus a little more positively I'm you
know I'm looking for my next opportunity
and launching in there to make that
connection but let's say you're at a
party and you meet people you haven't
met before wouldn't not asking about
their job at least during the
introduction process be a hard habit to
break I think it is a hard habit to
break I think we're all totally used to
this but I also think it is possible to
shift I talked to someone who felt like
her job had become her entire
personality who would just sit there
hoping that people would ask her what
she did for a living it made her feel
better about herself she said she kind
of were afraid that people before she
said what she did people would kind of
be thinking like who's this idiot and
throwing her title out there would kind
of be this thing that would make her
seem like a valuable person but she was
able to shift and now she asked people
how they feel their time and what brings
them Joy it might seem a little weird at
first but I think it's possible to shift
the conversation there's more to life
than just work exactly we're more than
our jobs all right that's Wall Street
Journal working life columnist Rachel
feinsick Rachel thanks so much for being
with us thanks so much for having me and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
thank you
[Music]